let's talk about vacations generally we
hear about Trump's taking a lot of
vacation he's playing golf a lot last
week I told you that Donald Trump was
starting a 17-day golf vacation at one
of his clubs and Donald Trump in the
White House have been going to great
lengths to portray him as working really
hard during this vacation at Bedminster
New Jersey Golf Club for example Donald
Trump tweeted very very astutely given
what it is that was ultimately revealed
working in Bedminster New Jersey as
long-planned construction is being done
at the White House this is not a
vacation meetings and calls on Saturday
an anonymous White House official
briefer an official did a briefing of
reporters about these supposed working
vacations and basically refused to admit
that Donald Trump would be playing any
golf despite the fact that he's taking a
17 day vacation at one of his own golf
clubs and he plays golf all the time and
this is just the best very shortly after
that press briefing about how Trump
isn't playing golf and is working hard a
video started circulating on Instagram
of Donald Trump rolling up in a golf
cart with golf clubs and saying hi to
some people that were on the golf course
take a look at this
at it right
I start doing a job so on the one hand
this is this is this is the real world
folks on the one hand the more time
Trump is playing golf sort of like less
time that he's doing horrible things but
on the other hand we should have a
president who will actually do some work
and from a completely objective point of
view in their first year in office so
far Trump has taken 60 vacation days
right this is through his first six and
a half months in his entire first year
Obama took 27 vacation days George W
Bush took 69 Bill Clinton took 21 George
HW Bush took 40 Reagan took 42 and
Carter took 19 Trump already 60 days
through just his first six and a half
months and this is what Trump is don't
get it's not that he's playing golf
that's the problem it's that he lies
about it it's that he went after Obama
endlessly about Obama's golf and it's
also that he's using taxpayer money to
fund these trips every one of these
trips is way more expensive than Obama's
golf trips Obama would play I don't
remember exactly but like at DC area
golf clubs he would play at a various
government or military golf clubs
whatever Trump is traveling to his own
golf clubs to play all the time he's
going to spend in one year what Obama
did in eight years on vacations and it's
the funneling of the taxpayer money and
it's his supporters who claim to be
fiscally conservative yet they seem to
have no problem with this and how absurd
is it that the White House brief you're
here he says that Trump wouldn't be
playing golf during his vacation I mean
we know the guy has blogged 47 rounds of
golf and often 57 million dollars
already
yeah and he's at his own Golf Resort
obviously he's going to be playing golf
I said this before I used to try to play
golf regularly and I was too busy to
play as much golf as Trump has played as
president of the United States and I was
not president of the United States or
anything nearly nearly as demanding it
is very very very bizarre and a lot of
Trump is don't care they don't seem to
understand hypocrisy in the same way
that they don't seem to understand
sarcasm but that's probably a story for
a different day new sponsor today for
the David Pakman show today's episode
made possible by Blue Sky binary
forex trading is a huge space millions
of traders around the world 80% of those
traders lose money in forex and usually
it's some combination of lacking the
appropriate knowledge maybe relying on
others like traders or auto trading
platforms instead of themselves getting
emotional taking big risks maybe not
following proper money management rules
and blue sky binary offers their
education course and they are a leading
financial education and tech company
specifically focused on forex they've
got senior traders with actual trading
experience and they offer a really well
structured and self-paced course in
forex to help with all of the above the
course includes video on-demand online
tests one-to-one sessions and access to
their community of traders to exchange
knowledge and experience and our viewers
and listeners can get a one-week free
trial at blue sky binary.com / David not
only does it include access to their
training platform but also you get a
session with a senior trader to go over
the basics of forex trading afterwards
it is $99.99 a month if you want to
continue you can stop and resume at any
point
check it out blue sky binary.com /d AV
ID